Schindler's List a basic helper of the
Jews Star Wars Episode one a Jedi bagman
begins Batman's trainer Ra's al Ghul
taken the greatest dad ever Liam Neeson
is my friend this move is called unknown
stars Liam Neeson my friend I'm gonna
keep saying that because I love him
honestly I just I really like Liam
Neeson even if the movie isn't that
great he just elevates it Liam Neeson
Liam Neeson I love him since Batman
Begins he's on fire every movie he's
done I've liked unknown is about a man
named dr. Martin Harris who's on a trip
to Berlin with his wife he's in a
terrible car accident losses fragments
of his memory but is able to remember
who he is he's positive he knows who he
is and when he finds his wife after a
four-day coma she acts like she has no
idea who he is there's a guy with her
who has replaced him who has the same
name who acts like he's Martin Harris
and Liam Neeson can't find his
identification or his passports or
anything everywhere he goes everything
that he thought was his life that was
all set up for him has been replaced
with something else or someone else has
now taken control of it so it's race to
figure out who is doing this to him
whether or not his wife is being
kidnapped or is being forced to do
something or what's going on exactly
it's a really great action thriller I
was really involved with the story Liam
Neeson just makes this film so much
better than it could have been it's very
very very similar to more an identity in
many ways now I love the Bourne films
this film is nowhere near as good as the
Bourne film whoever it has that same
drive the same kind of you're there with
this person it's it's the heat of the
moment you know not so much time passes
between the beginning this movie in the
end like it's it's all very in the mome
do you really feel there with that
person you know a lot of the supporting
cast does really well Diane Kruger gives
a really good performance I'm not sure
of his name but he goes to a man who's
good at finding people he's a former spy
and this guy is so entertaining he is
just he adds like all the eating tell
like he adds like all these quirks to
the character that obviously were not in
the script that he just came in was like
I was gonna be the awesomest little guy
ever the action of the film is done well
it's not too shaky I was very very
pleased with that I was worried about
that going in but it was all done very
well it's an efficient thriller it's a
fun thriller you know it's it's nothing
special it never rises above to be too
different but the fact that Liam Neeson
is so entertaining it and his character
is so likable as always it just gives
the film a really great feel you're
really there with him and you care for
him as a person I will say that I did
not think January Jones did a very good
job in this film I had a performance
it's pretty weak see Liam Neeson just at
this place work everything he does I'm
happy with Liam Neeson why not two
mediums like give me a million dollars
why finally am Neeson what is mine is
yours
it's like Liam Neeson doesn't woke up on
day one hey I'm Liam Neeson I'm the
greatest all my movies are going to be
great at this point all that has to
happen is for me to see Liam Neeson in
the cast and I'm officially interested
the guy's a beast unknowns a very fun
movie the only really flaws it hasn't
it's very similar you've seen this type
of thriller before but it's all done in
such an entertaining way that you know
you just deal with it it's it's fine you
know who cares so you've seen it before
Liam Neeson there's a few slow parts in
the middle and there is a few extra
characters that I didn't feel was
necessary I didn't really appreciate
Franklyn jealous character that much
he's a very good actor he's not used too
much here and I didn't really feel his
characters and was terribly necessary it
seemed like he was kind of an accessory
you know like just there because he's
Frank Langella it's just I thought even
though a lot of it was implausible a lot
of it started to make sense towards the
end and
I understood why certain things happen
the way they did and I appreciate this
film I liked it it's fun it's not as
good as taken so I'm gonna give unknown
three out of four stars it's a lot of
fun and I give Liam Neeson infinity
Sahar's give my friend